الان الى فقره التحليل العسكري وجلال شهده
واللواء فايز دويري تفضل جلال سلمى الابرز
اليوم طبعا اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي عن
مزيد من الخسائر في صفوف ضباطه وجنوده
وايضا صور لاقمار صناعيه البارحه تبرز
تواجد لاليات عسكريه اسرائيليه بكثافه في
المنطقه او الجهه الشرقيه من خانيونس
سنحلها بعد قليل مع اللواء فيز دويري
الخبير العسكري واستراتيجي سلام تطلعنا
اولا على مواقع الاشتباك خاصه المواقع
التي اعلن فيها عن سقوط مزيد من القتله
والجرحى من جنود قوات الاحتلال سلام يوم
ثقيل بالنسبه لجيش الاحتلال في غزه اليوم
بالفعل جلال قبل قليل فقط اعلن عن اجلاء
اكثر من 22 جندي مصاب بينهم اصابتين
خطيرتين اي قال الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان
له ان ال الاشتباكات تتركز في في منطقتين
في شمال ايه ال قطاع غزه وفي جنوب قطاع
غزه في الشمال في تقريبا جباليا وفي
الجنوب في منطقه رفح وا او في منطقه خان
يونس في محاوله لدخول مدينه خان يونس
وتطويقها كما كان يقول جيش الاحتلال قبل
اي قبل ايام سنبدا اذا من منطقه من جنوب
قطاع غزه خان يونس اليوم شهدت محاولات
اسرائيليه مكثفه لا اقتحام المدينه ولكن
كتائب القسام قالت انها صدت هذه ال اي
الهجمات وانها اشتبكت مع الجنود
الاسرائيليين بشكل مباشر وانها ايضا فجرت
عبوات ناسفه في جنود في قوه راجله في
منطقه خان يونس قبل ان ننتقل من خال يونس
ونقول ان المنطقه برمتها ب طبعا تتعرض
للقصف وللقصر الكثيف ليس فقط خان يونس بل
ايضا منطقه رفح تعرضت للقصف اليوم سنطلع
على صوره حصلت عليها الجزيره ل من الاقمار
الصناعيه هذه هي منطقه خان يونس في هذه
المربعات
هنا يمكن ان نرى بوضوح تمركز اليات للجيش
الاسرائيلي يبدو انها
كما قالت كتائب القسام لم تتمكن من التوغل
في المدينه بشكل كامل وبالتالي ايضا لم
تستطع حتى الان تطويق كامل مدينه خان يونس
القتال لا يزال مستمرا ووصفته ال جيش
الاحتلال وصف هذا القتال بالدار بينه وبين
كتائب عز الدين القسام في منطقه خان يونس
هذا في الجنوب بشكل محدد في جنوب قطاع غزه
بالانتقال الى شمال قطاع غزه الشمال ايضا
لا يزال منطقه ملتهبه خاصه
جباليا جب المنطقه شهدت اشتباكات قالت
عنها اسرائيل انها عنيفه جدا وايضا بيت
لاهيا وفي منطقه الشيخ رضوان في منطقه
الشيخ رضوان اليوم حدث شيء يعني حدث امني
كبير بالنسبه لقوات
الاحتلال كانت احدى القوات تحاول الدخول
في نفق تقول انه تابع لحركه المقاومه
لكتائب القسام في منطقه الشيخ رضوان كتائب
القسام تنبهت الى اقتراب احدى الوحدات
الاسرائيليه من هذه المنطقه وقامت بتفخيخ
مدخل هذا النفق و فانفجر وادى الى سقوط
عدد من القتلى الاسرائيليين اسرائيل قالت
اليوم انها ان خمسه من جنودها بين ضابط
وجندي قتل في قطاع غزه وقبل قليل اكد
مراسل الجزيره ان هناك طائرات مروحيه تقوم
باجلاء الجرحى هم لم يقولوا بشكل محدد ان
هؤلاء الجرحى سقطوا فقط في مناطق الشمال
ولكن على الاقل لدينا تاكيد بان جنديا
واحدا قتل على الاقل في تفجير نفق حي
الشيخ
رضوان سننتقل الى جبهه اخرى بموازاه ما
يجري في قطاع غزه الحدود اللبنانيه
الجنوبيه مع شمال اسرائيل كانت اليوم اي
شهدت توترا كبيرا حزب الله قال انه استهدف
او نفذ اكثر من 10 عمليات استهداف لمواقع
وا سكنات اسرائيليه
ابرز هذه الاستهدافات كان صاروخا مضادا
للدروع انطلق من لبنان وسقط بالقرب من هذه
من هذا الموقع موقع متات العسكري
الاسرائيلي على بعد تقريبا كيلومتر واحد
قتل احد المتعاقدين مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
في هذه الاستهدافات هذا ابرز ما كان
ميدانيا جلال عوده اليك ش شكرا لك سلام
اذا الصور التي حصلنا عليها البارحه صور
تظهر تمركز للاليات العسكريه في الجنوب
الجيش الاسرائيلي روج الى انه يحاصر
خانيونس بخبرتك العسكريه من تواجد هذه
الاليات هل يشي
ب سيطره محتمله او بانه يحاصر خانيونس كما
يقول يعني دعنا حتى اوضح الصوره دعنا نعود
ايام الى
الوراء دخلت القو جيش الاحتلال من شارع
كفيم وفي اليوم الاول وصلت الى صلاح الدين
في نقطه التقاطع تحركت جنوبا بضع مئات من
الامتار ثم اخذت بالاتجاه الجنوب الغربي
الى منطقه
المطاحن هي تقع للاعلى من كلمه صلاح الدين
لمن لا يعرف الخارطه في هذه المنطقه واجهت
مقاومه عنيفه ولم تستطع اكمال الحركه لانه
كانت الخطه الاولى كما اقراها
ترغب في عمل
احاطه عميقه نسبيا او مجازا وتصل الى
مستشفى الناصر ومنه تنزل جنوبا الى
المواصي لكن يبدو تعطلت الحركه فوجدت
الخيار البديل كان الحركه جنوبا مع شارع
صلاح الدين شارع صلاح الدين يفصل بن سهيلا
على الشرق عن خان يونس وبالتالي صور
الاقمار الصناعيه وضحت ثلاثه اماكن اذا
كانت تعرض الصوره الان قد تكون واضحه
للمشاهد هناك ثلاثه تجمعات كما كنا
نشاهدها في القاطع الشمالي من من غزه
فبالتالي هذه المناطق لاحظ هي مناطق يوجد
الاليات فيها واضحه في الصوره اللي في
اقصى الشاشه تجمع كبير
للاليات الصوره الوسطى عدد اقل في الصوره
الاولى عدد ياتي تقريبا موازي الى الصوره
الثالثه هذا في المنطقه الشرقيه ل خانيونس
نعم هذه هي سلكت شارع متفرع عن شارع صلاح
الدين و تمركزت في هذه المناطق لماذا
تتمركز لانها لا تستطيع ان تواصل تقدمها
تواجه مقاومه لانه هذه القوات ليست هي راس
الحربه وليست الموجه الاولى في الهجوم
هناك قوات تقاتل امامها هذه القوات تجبر
على التوقف حتى لا يصبح اكتظاظا في
الاليات فيختار ايه مناطق تكون خاليه او
فيها مساحه معينه يتم عمل السواتر
الترابيه وتتمركز هذه الاليات وهذا المشهد
تعودنا عليه في القاطع الشمالي لم يقدم
الكثير نعم ليس بالامر السهل والتعامل معه
يجب ان يكون ضمن خطه دفاعيه محكمه وهذا ما
نتوقعه من خلال متابعتنا
وال عمليه القياس على ما جرى سابقا
فبالتالي اتصور هذه الان لو عدنا لا في
نفس الخارطه لو سمحت لي اها لا نبقى نبقى
في في الجنوب نذهب الى الى الخارطه نبقى
في الجنوب الان ناتي الى بني سهيله لو
سمحت ل خارطه بني سهيله تظهر لنا الان
احنا تحدثنا عن الهجوم الذي دخل من كفيم
ولكن في
صلاحين هذا هذا احد اذرع الهجوم لكن كان
هناك هجومان او هجومين اثنين في في منطقه
عبسان الصغرى وعبس الكبرى وبني سهيله وتح
ويحاول كلا القوتين الالتقاء على شارع
صلاح الدين هذه القوات لم تستطع والحديث
الان عن الخسائر والمعارك الضاريه وما
شابه ذلك ونقل الجرحى بالطيارات العموديه
هي في منطقه بني سهيله وعبس الصغرى وعبس
الكبرى اذا دعني اقول دخلت قوات جيش
الاحتلال دخلت الى اعماق متباينه الان من
طري من شارع كسفي دخلت ودخلت الى تقريبا
الى الجزء الشرقي من مدينه خان يونس لكن
الواجهه الواجهه الاكثر خطوره والاكثر قوه
والاكثر عنف والتي حشد لها فرقه مظليين
كامله مدعمه بقوات الكوماندوز مدعمه
بالويه مدرعه لا تزال القتال في منطقه
عبسان الصغرى عبسان الكبرى وبني سهيله
والايا الساعات والايام القادمه هي التي
تعطي صوره واضحه عن حقيقه الوضع الميداني
في هذه المنطقه يعني الخلاصه بقراءتك
العسكريه لا حصار لخان يونس حتى الساعه
هذا لا يشير الى لغ ال لا لا يجد حتحول
الى حاوله اختراق كما
حدث في التوام وفي ابراج الكرامه طيب
نتحول الى الشمال ايضا رصدنا وهذه الصور
هي البارحه في السادس من الشهر الجاري
ايضا بشارع صلاح الدين مع تقاطع شار بغداد
ب بمنطقه الشجاعيه نلاحظ ايضا هذا نعم هذه
يعني
كانوا يعني عرضت هذه الصور وعرضت فيديوهات
توقعنا ان تكون اي الاحتمال الاكبر في
شارع بغداد والاحتمال الثاني في الجزء
الشمالي من شارع صلاح الدين دخلت هذه
الاليات وشاهدنا الفيديوهات في
اي مساء الامس الان هذه القوات تقدمت بضع
مئات من الامتار بضع مئات من الامتار
لانها لم تصل الى شارع العواميد وشارع
العواميد اي تقريبا نقطه تقاطع شارع بغداد
مع شارع صلاح الدين المسافه حتى التقاهم
العواميد اقل من 1 م وبالتالي هي الان لم
تستطع ان ان تكمل تقدمها لان هي تهدف الى
فصل الشجاعيه عن غزه القديمه
وفصل الزيتون الى جزئين الزيتون الغربي
والزيتون الشرقي ولكن العمليات هذا
الفيديو الذي اشرت اليه انت اللواء
الدويري عن المعارك التي عرضتها القسام
البارحه والتي حصلت في الشجاعيه الاستهداف
المباشر وكان الاقوى والاكثر وضوحا
لاستهداف الياسين
ليات عسكريه كتائب القسام تتحدث عن
حوالي 70 اليه عسكريه تم اصابتها اما
تدميرها بشكل مباشر او او بشكل جزئي على
مدى 72 سعه كيف تقرا هذا الرقم 79 اليه في
في المنطقه الشماليه شماليه تحدث عن جنوب
هناك خبر اخر تحدث عن تقريبا 132 اليه
المجموع الكلي للاليات التي دمرت كليا او
جزئيا في القاطع الجنوبي والقاطع الشمالي
اليه هكذا قرات يعني ونشرت من قبل القسام
132 اليه وهناك يعني الان اذا دخلنا في
التفصيلات ستجد في المكان كذا في الساعه
كذا في المكان كذا لكن الرقم الاجمالي 10
32 اليه 132 اليه مقاتله هي معدات تقريبا
لوى زائد اكثر من لوا تم تدمير الياته
خلال 72 ساعه واضح بالحديث عن الخسائر في
الاليات للجيش الاسرائيلي هناك خسائر في
المقابل ايضا للضباط والجنود الاسرائيليين
والجيش الاسرائيلي تباعا يعلن عنها بطبيعه
الحال خسائر كبيره حتى الساعه وهناك تململ
بحسب مدير مكتبنا في رام الله وليد العمري
من الاعداد الكبيره للخسائر في الجنود
والضباط الاسرائيليين جراء ما نشاهده الان
هذه الاستهدافات المب كان هناك خبر
يعني على الدرجه عاليه من
المصداقيه قتل رائد قتل رائد في
حادثه تفجير النفق ويقال بانه ابن رئيس س
الاركان
السابق جنازي
او ايزنكوت ايزوت طبعا هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه قالت بانه قتل صحيح وهو
ابن ونشروا صوره سابقه له ولابوه وبالتالي
الان يعني بدات ال نتائج المعركه من حيث
تدمير الاليات والقتلى وما شابه ذلك بدات
تصل بما انه الان وصلت الى ابن رئيس اركان
سابق ازن كوت وما وغيره الان لا يمكن
اخفاء الامر في المقابل لواء الدويري سلاح
صناعه اسرائيليه يعرف رامباج يطلق من الجو
الى الارض ما هذا السلاح يعني هذا هذا
صناعه محليه طائره اف 16 تحمل اربع صواريخ
الراس المتفجر 10 150 غم الوزن الاجمالي
558 غم مدام من 100 الى 150 كيلومتر حسب
الوضع هو سلاح فعال كيف يستخدم الان هذا
يستخدم ضد الجو وبالتالي يستخدم ضد الفاق
ضد التحصينات الى ما شابه ذلك وعندما
تتحدث مسل الاجمالي تقريبا نص طن دقيق
10 متر درجه الخطا احتماليه الخطا 10 متر
10 متر كيف يتم التحكم فيه الي نعم التحكم
الالي نعم تحكم الي ويمكن يمكن تغيير
مساره يمكن هذا هذا الصاروخ
يبرمج يتحرك باتجاه الهدف اذا كان الهدف
متحرك يمكن اعاده توجيهه او تغيير اتجاهه
لمهاجمه هدف اخر طيب اذا لديها هذ هذه
الذخائر لماذا لماذا تطلب مزيد من الذخائر
بسب درجه الاستهلاك العالي استهلاك عالي
استهلاك عالي يعني الان شركه رافائيل لا
تستطيع ان تزود الجيش الاسرائيلي بما
يحتاجه لمده اسبوع الان يذهب الى لوكهيد
رايثون وغير ذلك بالامس وصلت الطائره رقم
200 بالامس الطائره رقم 200 بنصف دقيقه
بلومبرج نقلت عن مسؤول اسرائيلي بان شبكه
الانفاق 500 متر 500 ر 500 م
عفوا كيف يمكن تدمير هذه الانفاق الان
الان البحث عن وسائل التدمير كثر الحديث
في الفتره الاخيره عن عمليات التغريق
واحضار ثلاثه مضخات كبيره عن وصواريخ مثل
هذه عملاقه الى غير ذلك المعلومات عن
الانفاق لا انا املكها ولا غير يملكها
يملكها حماس الان الحديث عن انفاق دفاعيه
انفاق هجوميه انفاق من طابقين انفاق من
ثلاثه طوابق الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بانها
اكبر من شبكه المترو في لندن هناك امر
كثير جدا يتم الحديث عنه وبالتالي شبكه
الانفاق لازالت الصندوق الاسود لا نستطيع
الخوض في تفاصيلها لاننا لا نعرف تفاصيلها
وحتى لو ن عرفنا تفاصيلها لن نخوض بتفاصيل
شكرا لك اللواء فيزير الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي التغطيه مستمره دائما على
شاشه الجزيره نعود لمتابعتها لمتابعتها
معك سلمى